今日はガチだしていく花粉です今日はですねあのー
言葉の勉強かねぇ
左脳
どれほど主観的な
活動であるかっていうことについて話ししたいんです
それですねなぜそういうことを考えたらと言うとじゃあ今あの頃なビルス様にも
大きな課題にはなってますよね
で
誰が一番さんをカラーウィレスに
その弱いかとかどのどういうような人が非常に五毒光
リリースを受けるかどんな人が祝いを
あ新都まで行きですねこのこれは頃のビルス
バイキンそのあってもですね
非常に病気になる愛だとそういうことがですね
その年齢とかいろんなファクターによって違ってきますだから人によって違うんです
けれども
でもう全部ジャブがそれ
そういうのですね熊谷ことはまだ科学的にはまあ我々知らないんですけれども
ある程度走ってもうわかってるわけでしょ
で父をよって違いますけれども客観的な
かっ客観的なファクターによって違ってくるんですよ
しかし言葉のがアップその勉強はですねそういう主観的な
その要素じゃなくてですねあくまで自分の態度
どれほどまあいいいくつかその態度
お嬢のですねいい
直面があるわけですね例えば
勉強している言葉が好きかどうかですね
勉強すること自体スキーかどうか
その勉強その流暢にですね話せるようになるだろうという自信があるかどうか
いろんなそういうファクターがあるわけですよ
あるいはその勉強すること自体がターちゃん聞いたりたくさん読んだりする事は非常に
大切ですから
者
読んでるないよ聞いているないよ
スキーかどうかですねー
あるいは聞いてる声が好きかどうかですね
そういうそういう主観的なパターがねぇ
非常に多いですそして我々の医師によってそういう4巻ファクターがねぇ
主観的な方も我々自分に対して影響与えることもできるわけですよ
こないですわまあ
人から生えてマスク被ってるぜいろいろいい
取れるそのパンがその措置があるけれども
13私が可能
かわいいです
あの美味しくないということだけではあまり影響ないんですよ
言葉の勉強は違うんですよ言葉の勉強はやりたい
スキーだと絶対できるんだとそういう悲観的なファクターが非常に大切です
だからよくその
調査があるんですよね
どういう人が嘘の言葉を
ちょのうまく勉強できるだとかあるいはどういうその実際の具体的な勉強の措置
活動やいう強敵か何時間
その勉強しないといけないだだとかそういうちょ調査はあるけれども
やはりあんまり大して意味はないと思うんですよというのは伊達はそれじゃあ
学校へですね1000時間勉強しないといけないといえば
しかしいっしょリゾーリの勉強してる人がですね
主観的に違うんですよ
ある人はもう
うんその
いわゆる学校へ行ってるそのクラスの中にいる時しか勉強しないわけでまあ勉強のもう
しないでしょ
聞いてるか読んでるかですねしかしある人はもうそれ以外の時でも
映画を見たり音楽を聴いたりすることもあるわけですよ
スキーからああ
でその好きというのはですね全部全部
例えばボカ日本語を勉強するしている時に戦もすべて日本の文化
脳から
何でも好きんだとそうじゃないんですよ
好きなものをある dusky なものを探してその好きなものを聞いたり読んだり
好きがし唐突ギャ付き合ってですね
全部全部好きっていうわけじゃないけれどもそういう私感的な
その要素をうまく利用した人たちがうまくべきをできるわけでしょそれは
その客観的なたとえばある人はその
上手なその言葉を勉強する
その二行ずの人たちはその読んでる時にその創造するあれ使用する推測するんですよ
すい数字をする意味が写真
6ヴァイスあまりそういうことをしないんですよね
いろんなだから基本的には主観的に勉強したい
できるスキー好きですとそういう人が自分なりな
のその
強化的評価的な勉強法を見つかるわけですよ
それをギャッ感的にその
並べることはたいした意味ばないとモンド紙はある程度作にはなるけれども基本はです
ね
その先生が教えるんじゃなくていい学校とか悪い学校とか良い教科書とか悪い教科書と
はそういう人じゃなくてあくまで
週間でいい勉強してる人どれほど
自信はあるかスピーカー
それがやはり
一番の基本の書 no 言葉の米木を勉強においての成功能書の基本要素だとパーカー
だと思います
じゃあ今日はそこまでどうもありがとう
さよならん
[音楽]
ん
んっ
[音楽]
ん
あ